alright so we talked a lot about the one
percent on the show and an interesting
study came out by Sadoff Investment
Research breaking down some of the
economics of what's going on in America
today so this is from 2012 the average
household income of Americans is about
thirty thousand dollars the average
household of the top one percenters is
about 1.2 million which is 41 times the
average family's income the average
household of the top point one percent
is about six million which is 206 times
the average family's income so what I
think is interesting about this is that
you know when you think of the one
percent I think people think this is
these are the people that have like you
know an armada of planes and houses
everywhere etcetera etc now they do have
over a million bucks which I think
probably all we all aspire to have and
this is America everybody should have
something but should we be focusing more
on that point one percent than the one
percent because that point one that six
million that's sort of where you're
getting into the ultra-rich although
even that is still leaving out all the
Zuckerberg xand the people that really
have the big power I've given you a lot
to chew on there well I don't know where
to begin I never think about the point
percent one percent i don'ti I mean like
it just it's so like after that number
gets so large it's like it's absolutely
meaningless to me it's like an make six
million a year I'm like great could be
six billion I don't like it's so
ridiculous my first thought was like
well you know it said like on Obama's
watch I'm like well I guess the only
good information is if it was on a
Republicans watch we'd be talking about
the point 0 0 1 making 12 million years
or something like that you know there's
only so much you can do but at the end
of the day everyone's got these sweet
notions that like oh our country was
founded on democracy it's capitalism I
mean capitalism Trump's democracy and
you can't really blame people for going
in you know into these money markets
into these hedge fund jobs they want to
make a lot of money that's their thing
and they make a lot of money and it's
like it's it's a really hard point you
just hope that they at the end of you
hope that they give back right that
you're making all this money that maybe
you can take you you know your personal
wealth and do good things with it and if
you don't you just hope you know that
they're miserable you know
horrible miserable people are they ever
miserable that's the question there
never is over six million dollars first
of all no I look it it's the it's the
it's the things that you I remember when
Warren Buffett was saying at one point
thing when the economy's crashing that
based on the taxes he was paying because
a lot of his income was off of
investments he was paying like I'm a
fifteen percent right whereas like like
normal people pain like thirty forty
percent so he was making a point about
that first of all about you know the
thing of taxing the rich a little bit
more in finding ways to get money from
them and the other thing was I just
heard yesterday it was saying some
company for the company was one of these
big companies caterpillar was a
caterpillar was uh underpaid like two
billion dollars in taxes or something
because they found ways to do it they
they moved all their profits to to a
Swiss bank account yeah so that's where
you go as we get upset you go dude like
I you know I'm paying our every dollar I
make I'm paying fifty cents of that to
the government and there's these big
companies are finding loopholes so
that's where you go come on man you know
let's let's spread a little bit of that
wealth I always thought that the Warren
Buffett thing was kind interesting cuz
he would always say well my secretary is
paying higher tax than I am which always
made me think well why you paying her so
little they like if you'd pay her more
than she closer to your tax bracket
should be doing ok pater with stocks
then then she would pay then then she
would not pay this you pay less tax but
it's because income yeah so that's
that's we get screwed yeah so the part
that you brought up is what this article
that was analyzing this was also saying
is that this gap between the ultra rich
and the poor has gotten significantly
bigger under Obama and I think we think
we all think somehow that it's the
Republicans that are really bad about
this but this is one of these things
where Obama has dropped the ball cuz the
facts are the facts I don't know if he's
drop the ball I just don't know how much
he can do you know in a way it's like
you do you talk about wall street
performer Wall Street that money feels
lobbyists snip fuels Congress like
there's only so much you're gonna do to
stop this money you know I mean I just
feel like it's you know it's it's like
that thing when it when they're like oh
operation run for president you know
you're like the most popular woman on
the planet she's like well why would I
give up all that power you know what I
mean so it so I don't know my everything
blah blame Obama constantly I mean on
Obama's election night all the bigwig
Republicans like got in that room and
they're like we're gonna do one thing
we're gonna block everything that he
intends to do and they have or they've
been very successful at that so I don't
know if you can keep going back with
Obamacare I don't think they like black
people yeah well that's that no it's
listen it's naive to think that one
person is gonna make you know be able to
run everything and all you have to do is
watch house of cards you realize the
vice president could be pulling the
strings yeah you know and there's a lot
of things that are you know backdoor
deals being made and it's just it's a
systemic thing unfortunately you know a
lot of other countries do tax you pay
more taxes but you you know you don't
have homeless people for example so is
the choice that we have to make do we
want to pay less taxes and have almost
people or more taxes and not have almost
people was that house occurrence your
way of telling us that you think Biden
is killed someone I think I justify kill
someone and uh it's a great show yeah it
is a pretty great show um how should we
generally feel about the super rich
people i'm not even talking about that
one percent then the the six million
people you know the people that bring in
6 Mendoza I'm talking about the the real
the billionaire billionaire people
should we be like this George Soros this
week just met with all the potential
Republican 2016 guys may it's like they
have to go kiss the ring just some rich
guy yeah it's pretty it's pretty sick
right well I mean this morning it comes
down and we have now less you know
restrictions on who can pay who to run
for election it's just yeah precor yeah
Thank You Supreme Court wait a reel it
in Supreme Court uh so now I can give my
you know ten bucks the Democrats all
right it's it's it's so you know it is
when you really think about it if you
feel powerless and its really horribly
discouraging but then you're like oh
there's a sale on wine and that solves a
lot of my problems when I think about
the super rich yeah so how do you feel
it's like listen man if they made the
money they want to do what they wanna do
they can do it it's just uh it the the
the one thing you do start worrying
about is if the UH the the disparity
continues then
you know if you look at history every
revolution has many revolution is based
on econ economics yeah so eventually
there's going to be a breaking point and
so I think at some point the the country
doesn't need to step back and go okay
let's we can't have that many more
people that are that are poor and this
few that are rich because eventually
something will ya 206 times the amount
of the average income these people are
making seems like a bit yeah and and the
loopholes it is it's infuriating and now
you know it's unfortunate but now
everyone's armed so I mean it literally
it could happen it could happen